I'm Mitt Romney i'm running for
president and I approve this message now
it's time for all conservatives to unite
and support Rick Santorum for president
at one extent it makes him unacceptable
to a large number of Republicans number
one is he wants us out of our wars and
number two he wants to legalize drugs I
think it's probably one of the more
important elections at least in my
lifetime I'm 60 years old in the past I
think people did have their minds made
up but this time I think there's a lot
more people that are welcome minded and
ND happy and looking for the person that
can win well I expect in my lifetime I
should see three major parties I believe
there will be some breakage and i think
democrats will lose some and Republicans
will lose them unfortunately when you
have an established system it's hard to
change that overnight I want a little
bit more fiscal responsibility and I
want some social compassion without
breaking the bank Romney was somebody
release us and it's not so much that I'm
in love with him as a candidate but I
think you can maybe win here tonight to
ask you to support with me repair for
president nited states from holland
receive more consultations from active
duty military personnel and all of the
other candidates i think there is a
movement of fraud I think Rand Paul
started
we were going to change this country
we're going to fix it
they may not be this time but it's going
to be next time it's just going to get
bigger and bigger I think he has a
pretty good chance I mean it's still up
in the air but I'm excited I think he's
gonna do well if we can hopefully get
the independents and Democrats he'll
probably do really well I'm just
grateful that the media is acknowledging
him at all she admitted to inform and
Romney Ron Paul still in the next three
tickets out which is obviously true and
and one of two that can actually run a
national campaign and raise the money
but there's nobody else to have people
like you working hard and enthusiastic
a little disappoint on asleep thought he
was going to come in first but third is
still good he came they can't say on the
media that he's off the radar now right
I'm kind of disappointed that he's not
in the first or second but it's still
good turnout it's really close it shows
the brilliance of the media how they can
manipulate public opinion and how they
can shave a race I'm waiting for the day
when we can say we're all Austrians now
I would love Ron Paul can win in 2012
but he understands just like any
educator that it's the future and he has
a son Rand Paul that is obviously very
successful a u.s. senator now and he's
advocating all the fine principles that
his dad has 4 30 years in Congress I
think there's nothing to be ashamed of
everything to be satisfied and be ready
gone on to the next stop which is New
Hampshire
Oh